the search continues for a man who lived
inside a mobile home that caught fire
last night leaving a woman and three
dogs dead the fire happened near
hollywood and sahara victoria saha back
on scene she joins us live as the
investigation unfolds victoria
a small memorial is placed right in
front of this mobile home with its
windows and doors boarded up and
assigned from the fire department making
sure no one enters and tampers with the
evidence
[Music]
this is all that's left of the mobile
home a charred roof and some things that
belong to those who lived here police
say before the flames broke out
wednesday afternoon they were here in
the morning because of a domestic
disturbance involving the victim who was
a woman and a man who is now nowhere to
be found
then a fire started in the same unit
around 4 pm wednesday video given to us
from a neighbor shows the flames and
smoke coming out of the roof it was
after the fire broke out that fire
officials found the woman dead with her
three dogs
some neighbors i spoke with say they
didn't know the victim but would often
see different people walking in and out
never been a very clean place i was on
my room i saw fire and i called my wife
and she told me not come home because
the smoke was taken over the house
police say a lot of water was used to
put out the fire which makes it hard to
examine the crime scene
while i was here earlier i came across
the family of the victim they say she
was 35 years old we hear from them
coming up tonight at five victoria saha
live local now